This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. August 24, 1814, marked the first and only time Washington DC was occupied by outside forces. The United States was two years into the war of 1812. They'd taken on Great Britain, which was then the greatest naval power in the world, and things weren't looking great for the American troops defending DC. That's producer Vivian Lee. British forces overtook the city and set fire to historic American landmarks including the Treasury building, the Capitol building, and even the White House. The siege became known as the burning of Washington.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯（Roman Mars）。1814年8月24日，华盛顿特区迎来了历史上第一次也是唯一一次被外部势力占领。当时美国卷入1812年战争已经两年了。他们与当时世界上最强大的海上力量英国交战，而保卫华盛顿特区的美国军队形势不容乐观。这是制作人薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）。英军攻占了这座城市，并纵火焚烧了美国历史上的标志性建筑，包括财政部大楼、国会大厦，甚至是白宫。这场围困后来被称为“华盛顿大火”。
But then a freak occurrence which in any other situation would have been a total disaster for DC, saved the city. Dark clouds began to form, which turned into thunder and lightning, which then turned into a full-blown tornado that headed straight for the British who were setting fires around the capital. A number of British soldiers were killed by fallen debris, and the fires were extinguished by the rain.
但随后发生了一件离奇的事情——在任何其他情况下，这对华盛顿特区来说都是一场彻头彻尾的灾难，但它却拯救了这座城市。天空中开始聚拢黑云，随后电闪雷鸣，紧接着演变成一场货真价实的龙卷风，径直朝那些在首都各处放火的英军袭去。许多英国士兵被落下的瓦砾砸死，大火也被雨水扑灭。
The British retreated back to their ships, which had been severely damaged by the storm. Thanks to a simple act of weather, the occupation of our nation's capital was over within a little more than a day. The storm that saved Washington was just one of countless times that weather played a crucial factor in war. Napoleon's army was not defeated by Russian forces, but by a Russian winter. During World War II, General Patton famously distributed 250,000 prayer cards to the army to enlist as many men as possible to pray for an end to the reign. The battlefield has always been at the mercy of the climate, but there was a time in US military
英军撤回了他们的战舰，这些战舰在风暴中严重受损。多亏了一场简单天气现象，对我们国家首都的占领在短短一天多一点的时间里就结束了。拯救华盛顿的风暴只是天气在战争中扮演关键角色的无数次事件之一。拿破仑的军队不是被俄军打败的，而是被俄军的冬天击垮的。在二战期间，巴顿将军曾做过一件著名的举动：向全军发放了25万张祈祷卡，号召尽可能多的士兵祈祷战争早日结束。战场一直听命于气候，但在美国军事史上
history when we did more than just pray for advantageous weather. We tried to create it. Fighting Communist guerrillas in South Vietnam continues a slow grind. Pictures from the swampy May Kong Delta show government troops trying to ferret out the Vietnam Kong in a situation whose issue according to U.S. Beginning in the 1950s and continuing into the 1960s and 70s, the U.S. became deeply entangled in a war between North and South Vietnam. North Vietnam was supported by the Soviet Union, China, and other communist allies.
曾有一段时间，我们不仅祈祷能有有利的天气，我们还试图创造天气。在南越打击共产主义游击队的战斗进展缓慢。来自沼泽密布的湄公河三角洲的照片显示，政府军正试图搜捕越共，而根据美国的说法，局势的发展……从20世纪50年代开始并延续到60和70年代，美国深深陷入了越南南北双方的战争中。北越得到了苏联、中国以及其他共产主义盟友的支持。
South Vietnam was supported by the U.S. and other anti-communist allies. And the Vietnam War, or as the Vietnamese called it, the American War, was unlike any the United States had ever engaged in. Our tradition and our heritage and our education in our history all prepared us for a different kind of war than we had to fight in the late 60s. This is General Merrill McPeak, former chief of staff of the Air Force. There wasn't a front line, and we weren't facing an enemy, at least to the beginning, that was equipped with tanks and flamethrowers and high speed computers and so forth. It was a total mismatch from that standpoint. It was us against a guerrilla army that showed up occasionally and
南越则得到了美国和其他反共盟友的支持。越南战争，或者正如越南人所称的“美国战争”，与美国以往参与过的任何战争都不同。“我们的传统、我们的传承、我们在历史教育中的积淀，都让我们为另一种战争做好了准备，而不是我们在60年代末不得不打的那种战争。”这是空军前参谋长梅里尔·麦克皮克（Merrill McPeak）将军。当时没有前线，我们面对的敌人——至少在初期——没有配备坦克、火焰喷射器、高速计算机等等。从这个角度来看，这是一场极不对称的较量。是我们对阵一支偶尔露面、
then disappeared, vanished. And we spent the next months looking for it and then it showed up suddenly and then was gone again. That guerrilla army was the Viet Cong, a communist force allied with North Vietnam, but fighting primarily in the South. One of the Viet Cong's greatest advantages was the Ho Chi Minh Trail, a supply route that ran from North Vietnam through parts of Laos and Cambodia into South Vietnam. Hundreds of thousands of North Vietnamese troops used it to infiltrate the south with weapons
然后又消失得无影无踪的游击队。我们花了好几个月的时间寻找他们，然后他们突然出现，接着又消失了。那支游击队就是越共，一支与北越结盟但主要在南方作战的共产主义武装力量。越共最大的优势之一就是胡志明小道，这是一条从北越经老挝和柬埔寨部分地区延伸至南越的补给线。成千上万的北越军队利用这条小道将武器和物资渗透到南方。
and supplies. It traveled through an isolated region full of rugged mountains and dense jungles. The trail itself was made up of dirt paths and hand-made tunnels. Along the way, there were hidden bunkers, barracks, and even hospitals cleverly camouflaged from above. It was a engineering marvel, it wasn't a single road, it was a network of amazes of roads. The covert trail system dramatically shortened the journey from north to south Vietnam, meaning more troops, more weapons, and more North Vietnamese support could be made available to communist forces in the South.
它穿过了一个人迹罕至的地区，那里山峦起伏，丛林密布。小道本身由泥土小路和手工挖成的隧道组成。沿途有隐藏的地堡、营房，甚至还有从上方看经过巧妙伪装的医院。这是一个工程奇迹，它不是一条单一的道路，而是一个由错综复杂的道路组成的网络。这条秘密的小道系统极大地缩短了从北越到南越的行程，这意味着可以为南方的共产主义军队提供更多的部队、更多的武器和更多的北越支持。
And the key thing was that's how all their supplies, they supplied both the yet Kong and also their own forces, had to come down that trail. This is Lieutenant General Ed Soister. And in order to cut off the supplies, which are, of course, very important for military operation, we had to close this trail by various means. The US military tried disrupting the trail with bombing campaigns and by plowing the jungles
关键在于，他们所有的物资——他们既要给越共供货，也要给自己的部队供货——都必须通过这条小道运送下来。这是中将埃德·索斯特（Ed Soister）。为了切断对军事行动至关重要的物资供应，我们必须用各种手段关闭这条小道。美军试图通过轰炸行动和用犁铲平丛林来破坏这条小道，
to strip the land. They also used deadly chemical defolence like agent orange. But none of these tactics seemed to work, at least not for very long. So whenever we punched a hole in one part of it, they simply moved over to a bypass. There was only one thing that significantly slowed
以剥除地表植被。他们还使用了像橙剂这样致命的落叶剂。但这些战术似乎都不起作用，至少维持不了多久。所以每当我们在这条小道的某处打开一个缺口时，他们就会简单地转移到一条绕行路线上。只有一件事显著延缓了胡志明小道上物资和人员的流动：
the flow of supplies and people on the Ho Chi Minh Trail. Rain. The reality was that because of the nature of the trail, it was affected by heavy rainfall. So they had the same problem, of course, as we did in terms of trails that were very, very muddy with the rain. The mud would make the trails difficult to navigate, and so during one monsoon season in the middle of the war. Somebody, certainly not me, came up with the idea of,
雨。现实情况是，由于小道的性质，它受到了强降雨的影响。因此，他们在那些因下雨而变得非常泥泞的小道上面临着与我们同样的问题。泥泞使得小道难以通行，于是在战争中期的某个季风季节里，
let's see if we can increase the rainfall enough to stop vehicular traffic. The Department of Defense had decided that they should try to control the weather. This was the beginning of a top secret military project called Operation Popeye. The goal was to actually create more rain in Southeast Asia by artificially extending and intensifying
有人——当然不是我——想出了一个主意：“让我们看看能不能增加降雨量，大到足以阻止车辆通行。”国防部决定尝试控制天气。这就是绝密军事项目“大力水手行动”（Operation Popeye）的开端。其目的是通过人为延长和强化自然发生的季风季节，在东南亚制造更多的雨水。
the naturally occurring monsoon season. The monsoon season typically lasted from April to October. The US military believed that if it could extend it by a month on either side, it would create a huge strategic advantage. Humans, especially military humans, have wanted to control the weather for a long time. It goes back to traditional rain making to ceremonies. This is Jim Fleming.
季风季节通常从4月持续到10月。美军认为，如果能在两端各延长一个月，就会创造巨大的战略优势。人类，尤其是军事领域的人类，长期以来一直想要控制天气。这可以追溯到传统的求雨仪式。这是吉姆·弗莱明（Jim Fleming）。
He's studied the history of human attempts at weather and climate modification. He doesn't think very highly of our abilities. It turns out that if you do a rain dance for up to two weeks, it'll probably rain, and then you could take credit for that. I mean, if you do anything long enough, and consistently enough, it'll rain, and you can claim responsibility. Flaming says that in the 19th century, after the Civil War, a theory began to develop, that major military operations were somehow disrupting the clouds and causing big rainstorms.
他研究过人类试图改造天气和气候的历史。他对我们的能力评价不高。事实证明，如果你连续跳长达两周的求雨舞，可能会下雨，然后你就可以把功劳揽在自己身上。我的意思是，如果你做一件事的时间足够长、且足够持续，天就会下雨，而你就可以宣称那是你的功劳。弗莱明说，在19世纪内战之后，开始流传这样一种理论：重大的军事行动不知何故破坏了云层并引发了大暴雨。
And so the theory was that we could shoot cannon fireworks, set off hydrogen balloons. We could sort of imitate battle. Imitate battle in order to create rain. The federal government actually attempted this in Texas in the 1890s during a drought. The actual Department of Agriculture funded it, and they had a weather bureau observer there. And the locals loved it. They loved the fireworks.
因此当时的理论是，我们可以发射大炮焰火、升起氢气球。我们可以某种程度上模仿战斗。模仿战斗以制造降雨。19世纪90年代干旱期间，联邦政府实际上在德克萨斯州尝试过这样做。农业部资助了这个项目，他们还在当地派驻了一名气象局观察员。当地人非常喜欢它。他们喜欢焰火。
They loved the spectacle. They loved to go out on the hillside and watch the cannonating. But it was during the monsoonsies. And so there was a really good chance it was going to rain anyway. This kind of experimentation continued from the 1890s into the early 20th century, and it only accelerated after 1945. We'd enter the Cold War era, and we'd just invented
他们喜欢这种奇观。他们喜欢去山坡上观看炮击。但当时正值季风季节。因此，无论如何都很有可能会下雨。这种实验从19世纪90年代一直持续到20世纪初，并在1945年之后加速发展。我们进入了冷战时代，而我们刚刚发明了
the bomb. And that technology made people think they had power over nature. It also heightened our paranoia that other countries were trying to develop their own nature controlling technologies like the Russians. Before the space race with the Soviet Union, there was a kind of weather race. We thought that they might get ahead of us and if they had a nefarious purpose, they might be able to change our weather and climate and possibly cause another dust bowl or drought or something if they really could do it.
原子弹。这项技术让人们觉得自己拥有了驾驭自然的力量。这也加剧了我们的偏执，让我们担心其他国家也在试图开发他们自己的自然控制技术，比如苏联人。在与苏联展开太空竞赛之前，还存在着一种天气竞赛。我们认为他们可能会领先于我们，如果他们有什么不怀好意的目的，他们可能会改变我们的天气和气候，如果他们真的能做到这一点的话，甚至可能引发另一场尘暴、干旱或其他灾难。
So there was a great rush to get into this field. Again, it was driven by military concerns. There was a lot of money being poured into scientific research on weather control. And while many of these experiments didn't yield very promising results, one actually did in 1946. Well, the first time in all history, there is now open demand, actually did in 1946. This remarkable achievement happened in Sconnected the New York at the offices of General Electric. Yep, the same company that made your dishwasher
因此，人们争先恐后地涉足这一领域。同样，这也是由军事需求驱动的。当时有大量资金涌入天气控制的科学研究。虽然其中许多实验并没有产出令人满意的结果，但其中一个确实在1946年成功了。好吧，历史上破天荒第一次，现在有了公开需求，实际上在1946年就成功了。这一卓越的成就在纽约斯克内克斯塔（Schenectady）的通用电气公司（GE）办公室里发生。没错，就是那个制造你家洗碗机的公司，
also invented weather control. GE was where a scientist and Nobel laureate named Irving Langmier was working in collaboration with a colleague named Vincent Schaeffer. Who developed a technique of dry ice put into a cloud that would make it super cool and force it to be conditions to go wavelose freezing and a little bit of ice in the cloud could cause a cloud to glaze shade or create snow. In case you didn't quite get that, here's a quick lesson in eighth grade cloud physics.
它也发明了天气控制。通用电气公司有一位名叫欧文·朗缪尔（Irving Langmuir）的科学家兼诺贝尔奖得主，他当时正与一位名叫文森特·谢弗（Vincent Schaeffer）的同事合作。他们开发了一种技术：将干冰投入云层中，这会使云层超冷却，迫使其达到冰点以下的条件，云层中的一点点冰就能使云层冰川化或产生雪。如果你没完全听懂，这里有一堂关于八年级云物理学的快课。
Clouds are essentially just tiny droplets of water suspended in the atmosphere. When the right conditions occur, water molecules in these clouds will condense together and become heavy enough to fall to earth as rain or snow. And that's what there was another guy doing instrumental work at GE. His name was Bernard or Bernie Vonnegut, the brother of author Kurt Fonegott, who also worked at GE in the PR department. And it's interesting. You can actually see the ways that GE influenced some of Fonegott's writing. Kurt was on staff at GE writing his reports, but he was also working on novels, you know,
云本质上只是悬浮在大气中的微小水滴。当条件合适时，这些云中的水分子会凝结在一起，变得足够重，从而作为雨或雪落到地面上。就在那时，通用电气公司还有另一个人在做着具有决定性的工作。他的名叫伯纳德或伯尼·冯内古特（Bernard / Bernie Vonnegut），他是作家库尔特·冯内古特（Kurt Vonnegut）的弟弟，当时也在通用电气公司的公关部门工作。有趣的是。你实际上可以看出通用电气影响冯内古特某些写作的方式。库尔特当时在通用电气公司的员工名单上撰写报告，但他也同时在创作小说，你知道的，
like Cats' Cradle, in which the mad, kind of like an Irving Langmer person, develops ice-nine, which messes up the environment. Ice-nine was kind of like cloud seeding on steroids. It's clear that Bernie and Kurt, these two brothers, were uneasy about some of the breakthroughs they were involved with. And I think you'll see some of Bernie's concerns reflected in Kurt Vonnegut's novels,
比如《猫的摇篮》（Cats' Cradle），书里那个疯狂的、有点像欧文·朗缪尔式的人物，发明了“冰-九”（Ice-nine），把环境搞得一团糟。《冰-九》有点像强力催化版的播云造雨。很显然，伯尼和库尔特这两兄弟对他们所参与的一些突破性进展感到不安。我想你会看到伯尼的一些担忧反映在库尔特·冯内古特的小说中，
which are pretty much against militarization of nature. But Bernie's work at GE actually helped lay the groundwork for that militarization. Along with Langmier and Schaefer, he made another critical discovery. He found a new weather-related use for a compound called silver iodide. It had a hexagonal structure, like a snowflake. And he found that if you sprayed it into a cloud, it would trick the cloud into glaciating. And so armed with a Nobel Prize winner, a technique to super cool a cloud with dry eyes, and a technique to trick a cloud with silver iodide, they really felt they had the basis for chemical cloud seeding. GE was understandably very proud of their discovery.
这些小说基本上都是反对自然军事化的。但伯尼在通用电气的工作实际上为这种军事化奠定了基础。除了朗缪尔和谢弗之外，他还做出了另一个重大发现。他发现了一种名为碘化银的化合物在天气方面的新用途。它具有六边形结构，就像雪花一样。他发现如果你把它喷洒到云层中，它就会诱使云层冰川化。因此，手握一位诺贝尔奖得主、用干冰使云层超冷却的技术，以及用碘化银诱骗云层的技术，他们真的觉得他们有了化学人工降雨的基础。通用电气理所当然地为他们的发现感到骄傲。
And so they issued a great big press release that said we can control the weather. But shortly after claiming responsibility for a storm that caused eight inches of snowfall in upstate New York, GE suddenly realized that they might not want to be known for controlling the weather, especially if that weather was destroying people's property. With it several months, their lawyer says, no, you better keep that quiet because there could be too many lawsuits.
因此他们发布了一份大肆宣称的新闻稿，称我们可以控制天气。但在声称对一场导致纽约州北部降雪八英寸的风暴负责后不久，通用电气突然意识到，他们可能不想因为控制天气而闻名，尤其是如果这种天气正在摧毁人们的财产的话。在几个月内，他们的律师说：“不，你最好保持低调，因为可能会有太多的诉讼。”
Given the risk of negative public reaction and liability, weather modification research continued quietly. Scientists explored how it could be applied to hurricane intervention and drought relief, and of course warfare. Langmur himself was excited about the military applications of his research. And I think he wanted to have a kind of a gigantic role
鉴于负面公众反应和法律责任的风险，天气改造研究悄悄地继续进行。科学家们探讨了它如何应用于飓风干预和抗旱，当然还有战争。朗缪尔本人对他的研究的军事应用感到兴奋。我认为他希望通过将天气用作军事化武器，来扮演某种巨大的角色。
by using weather as a militarized weapon. A hurricane is multiple H bombs and incredible destructive power if you could direct it against an enemy. So lightning was making these kind of claims. And so were our political leaders. With nuclear weapons now in play, the US was looking forward
如果你能将飓风引导针对敌人，飓风就相当于多枚氢弹，具有令人难以置信的破坏力。因此，朗缪尔提出了这类主张。我们的政治领导人也是如此。随着核武器的登场，美国正放眼未来，
and imagining how we could give ourselves an edge in future wars. This is from a speech that Vice President Lyndon Johnson gave in 1962. It lays the predicate in the foundation for the development of a weather satellite. That will permit man to determine the world's cloud layer. And ultimately, to control the weather, and he who controls the weather will control the world.
设想我们如何在未来的战争中占据优势。这段话摘自副总统林登·约翰逊（Lyndon Johnson）于1962年发表的一场演讲。它为气象卫星的发展奠定了前提和基础。这将使人类能够探测世界的云层。并最终控制天气，而谁控制了天气，谁就控制了世界。
LBJ, or Bondvillen, you decide. By the time Rainmaking had made its way to the Ho Chi Minh Trail in Southeast Asia, it wasn't a new technology, but it was still a closely held secret. Operation Popeye was a Navy program and missions were flown by Air Force pilots and those pilots were given limited information about what they were doing. I never I never even imagined that that group was doing until we got over there and showed up for the briefing and then they told us what this project was about.
是林登·约翰逊（LBJ），还是大反派，由你决定。当人工降雨传到东南亚的胡志明小道时，它已经不是什么新技术了，但它仍然是一个严守的秘密。“大力水手行动”是一个海军项目，任务由空军飞行员执行，而这些飞行员只被告知了关于他们正在做的事情的有限信息。“我甚至……我做梦也没想到那个小组在做什么，直到我们飞到那里去听简报，然后他们才告诉我们这个项目是关于什么的。”
This is Brian Heckman, a former Air Force pilot. He belonged to the 54th Weather Reconnaissance Squadron. They contributed to the 2,602 cloud-seating missions flown during Operation Popeye. We just went around looking for clouds to seed. Once they found a cloud to fly through, they'd flip a switch to ignite silver or lead iodide flares, then they'd wait to see if the cloud produced rainfall. There were times when we left an area that we had been working and it was obvious that there was a lot of rainstorms going on.
这是前空军飞行员布赖恩·赫克曼（Brian Heckman）。他隶属于第54气象侦察中队。他们参与了“大力水手行动”中执行的2602次人工降雨任务。我们只是四处寻找可以播撒催化剂的云。一旦他们找到一朵可以穿过的云，他们就会拨动开关点燃银或铅碘化银火炬，然后等待看这朵云是否能产生降雨。有时当我们离开一个我们一直在作业的区域时，很明显那里有很多暴雨正在发生。
Operation Popeye had four main objectives to turn the roads to mud, to cause landslides along roadways, to wash out river crossings, and to keep roads muddier for longer than usual. It seemed to heckman that Operation Pop-I was working, but it's really hard to know for sure. Cloud seating at the time and even today is far from an exact science. At best the military could measure three things, what the average rainfall for that area was, what the estimated rainfall would have been and what actually fell after a seating mission.
“大力水手行动”有四个主要目标：将道路变成泥泞、引发道路沿线的山体滑坡、冲毁河流渡口，并让道路保持泥泞的时间比平时更长。在赫克曼看来，“大力水手行动”起作用了，但很难确切知道。当时乃至今天的人工降雨都远非一门精确的科学。军方充其量只能测量三件事：该地区的平均降雨量是多少、估计降雨量本应该是多少，以及在一次播撒任务后实际降落了多少雨。
But they couldn't collect that much data, like enough to really rigorously analyze the outcomes. Here's Fleming again. The rain is completely variable. You have tremendous temporal variability, spatial variability, and that means the statistics are not robust about what your particular intervention did to that particular rainfall. And even if they could make it rain, they couldn't precisely control where that rain landed. One official described accidentally dumping a ton of rain on an American Special Forces camp. Still, the program was deemed effective enough to continue for five years, from 1967 to
但他们无法收集那么多的数据，无法达到能够真正严格分析结果的程度。再次请出弗莱明。降雨是完全多变的。你有巨大的时间变异性、空间变异性，这意味着关于你的特定干预对特定降雨做了什么的统计数据并不稳健。即使他们能造出雨，他们也无法精确控制雨落在哪里。一位官员曾描述不小心把一吨雨倾泻在一个美国特种部队营地上。尽管如此，该项目仍被认为足够有效，得以持续了五年，从1967年一直持续到
1972. But the biggest problem with Operation Popeye wasn't so much the lack of quantifiable success, it was the many ethical concerns. Whether modification, especially in the context of war, raises a lot of thorny questions. The military justified the program by arguing that increasing rainfall to great mud and wash out roads was preferable to more bombing. But the reality is, the US military still dropped a lot of bombs on Southeast Asia during the Vietnam War.
1972年。“大力水手行动”最大的问题与其说是缺乏可量化的成功，不如说是许多伦理方面的担忧。天气改造，尤其是在战争的背景下，引发了许多棘手的问题。军方为该项目辩护称，通过增加降雨来制造泥泞和冲毁道路，总比投放更多的轰炸要好。但现实情况是，在越南战争期间，美军仍然向东南亚投掷了大量的炸弹。
Over 7 million tons of them, so many in fact, that to this day, the government of Laos is still trying to clean up all of the undetnated bombs scattered across the country. Here's General Merrill McPeak again. So we dropped more bombs on Laos than we did on Germany and Japan all together in World War II. So the tonnage of bombs dropped was enormous, and the heavily used parts of the Ho Chi Minh Trail looked like the face of the moon. It was just a lunar landscape, nothing but dust. But just as it's unclear how much rain was generated by Operation Pah-Pai, it's also unclear if Pah- Popeye actually prevented the military from dropping more bombs, or if they just did both.
超过700万吨，数量之多以至于时至今日，老挝政府仍在努力清理散落在全国各地的所有未爆弹。再次请出梅里尔·麦克皮克将军。因此，我们在老挝投下的炸弹比我们在二战中对德国和日本投下的总和还要多。因此投下的炸弹吨位是巨大的，胡志明小道使用频繁的地区看起来就像月球表面。它只是一片月球般的景观，除了尘土什么也没有。但正如不清楚“大力水手行动”究竟产生了多少雨一样，同样不清楚的是，“大力水手行动”是否真的阻止了军方投掷更多的炸弹，或者他们只是两样都做了。
And messing with another country's weather system, that has potentially big and unpredictable consequences. You don't necessarily know what the long-term consequences are going to be of rainmaking. This is Jacob Hamlin, a historian at Oregon State University. Especially if you're doing it on a long-term basis. And there are documented cases in which weather modification may have caused harm.
干涉另一个国家的天气系统，可能会产生巨大且不可预测的后果。你未必知道人工降雨的长期后果会是什么。这是俄勒冈州立大学的历史学家雅各布·汉姆林（Jacob Hamlin）。特别是如果你长期这么做的话。并且有记录在案的案例表明，天气改造可能已经造成了危害。
The silver iodide sprayed into clouds can be toxic to humans and concentrated doses, but it hasn't been shown to have negative health effects when used for cloud seeding. Nevertheless, cloud seeding may have caused other problems. In 1947, Irving Langmuir's research team at GE tried to break up a hurricane by dumping a lot of dry ice into it to see if it would collapse, but instead it changed trajectory, became stronger and hit the Georgia coast.
喷洒到云层中的碘化银在浓缩剂量下对人类可能有毒，但在用于人工降雨时尚未被证明有负面健康影响。尽管如此，人工降雨可能已经引发了其他问题。1947年，欧文·朗缪尔在通用电气的研究团队试图通过向飓风中倾倒大量干冰来将其瓦解，看它是否会消散，但事与愿违，它改变了轨迹，变得更强并袭击了佐治亚州海岸。
One death was reported as a result of the hurricane. And in 1952, the British Royal Air Force was conducting cloud-sitting tests in Lin-Mith, England and may have accidentally caused a devastating flood that killed 35 people. It was this kind of ethical ambiguity that ultimately ended the US military's entire weather weaponization program.
据报道，这场飓风造成了一人死亡。1952年，英国皇家空军在英格兰林米思（Lynmouth）进行人工降雨测试时，可能不小心引发了一场毁灭性的洪水，夺去了35人的生命。正是这种伦理上的模棱两可，最终结束了美军整个天气武器化项目。
In 1971, Jack Anderson, a reporter for the Washington Post, published an article revealing that the US was engaged in covert weather warfare in Vietnam. This report was corroborated by information leaked in the Pentagon papers. The following year in July of 1972, Seymour Hirsch reported in the New York Times about Operation Popeye. Within two days of the story's publication, the entire program was officially ended, and all cloud-seating missions stopped.
1971年，《华盛顿邮报》记者杰克·安德森（Jack Anderson）发表了一篇文章，披露美国正在越南进行秘密天气战。这一报道得到了《五角大楼文件》中泄露的信息的证实。第二年（1972年7月），西摩·赫什（Seymour Hersh）在《纽约时报》上报道了“大力水手行动”。在该报道发表后短短两天内，整个项目就被正式叫停，所有人工降雨任务全部停止。
When the program was finally declassified, and it came out that the U.S. had been secretly engaging in hostile weather manipulation in Vietnam, it was dubbed the Watergate of Weather Warfare. But they really should have called the Watergate of Weather Warfare. But they really should have called it Weathergate. This led to an embarrassingly embarrassing moment for the US. Here's Jim Flemingen. It's perceived as a big mistake. It's just an embarrassment that you would try to intervene in a nation's weather like
当该项目最终被解密，并且美国一直在越南秘密进行敌意天气操纵的消息曝光后，它被戏称为天气战的“水门事件”。但他们真的应该把天气战的水门事件称为……但他们真的应该把它叫做“天气门”（Weathergate）。这给美国带来了一个极其尴尬的时刻。这是吉姆·弗莱明。这被视为一个大错误。你竟然试图这样干预一个国家的天气，这纯粹是一件尴尬的事。
that. Research money for weather control rapidly disappeared. And in 1977, the U.S. signed an international agreement called the Environmental Modification Convention Treaty, or INMOD for short, along with the Soviet Union and many other nations. They agreed to ban modification of the environment for hostile purposes. The treaty outlawed causing earthquakes and tsunamis, steering hurricanes or tampering with the ionosphere. It also banned any other widespread long-lasting
天气控制的研究经费迅速消失。1977年，美国与苏联以及许多其他国家签署了一项名为《环境改造公约条约》（简称ENMOD）的国际协议。他们同意禁止将环境改造用于敌对目的。该条约取缔了引发地震和海啸、操纵飓风或篡改电离层的行为。它还禁止任何其他广泛、持久和严重的
and severe damage to the environment. But there are questions about whether the end-mod treaty was even that relevant. It was very easy to ban environmental warfare. And the reason it was easy to ban is because you're not giving up anything. Because those things no longer were considered warfare. And the reason it was easy to ban is because you're not giving up anything, because those things no longer were considered to be important parts of the arsenal. They were developed during a time when the US wanted to develop lots of different weapons systems.
环境破坏。但对于《环境改造公约》条约是否真的那么具有现实意义，人们存在疑问。禁止环境战争是非常容易的。而容易禁止的原因在于你没有放弃任何东西。因为这些东西不再被认为是战争的重要组成部分。禁止的原因在于你没有放弃任何东西，因为这些事情不再被认为是军火库的重要组成部分。它们是在美国想要开发许多不同武器系统的时期开发的。
But by the time you get to the 1960s, if there was going to be a war with the Soviet Union, it was going to be a nuclear war. It was going to be a war in which thermonuclear weapons were used, intercontinental ballistic missiles were probably going to be a nuclear war. It was going to be a war in which thermonuclear weapons were used, intercontinental ballistic missiles were probably going to be used. And so, Hamlin believes that giving up environmental warfare was more a gesture of global cooperation rather than an actual step towards its disarmament. After all, it's hard to find something that can cause more widespread, long-lasting, or severe damage to the environment than nuclear weapons.
但到了20世纪60年代，如果爆发与苏联的战争，那将是一场核战争。那将是一场使用热核武器的战争，洲际弹道导弹可能会被……那将是一场使用热核武器的战争，洲际弹道导弹可能会被使用。因此，汉姆林认为，放弃环境战争更多是一种全球合作的姿态，而不是走向裁军的实际一步。毕竟，很难找到比核武器更能对环境造成更广泛、持久或严重破坏的东西了。
Those certainly were not banned. So the Enmont Treaty, you could argue, yes, sure, it's progress, but I would encourage us all to take a more cynical view of that and see that it was signed for very political purposes and really gave virtually nothing up. The military interest in weather control had run its course, but cloud seating is something that still takes place all over the world for another reason. Money. A major percentage of the economy is weather sensitive, from agriculture to energy to insurance
这些武器当然没有被禁止。因此，你可以争辩说，《环境改造公约》条约的确是进步，但我鼓励大家对它抱持更为冷嘲热讽的看法，看到它是出于非常政治化的目的而签署的，实际上几乎没有放弃任何东西。军方对天气控制的兴趣已经走到了尽头，但人工降雨出于另一个原因至今仍在世界各地进行。金钱。从农业、能源、保险到旅游业，很大一部分经济都对天气敏感。
to the travel industry. More than 50 countries openly have some form of weather modification program. China attempted to use cloud seating to clear skies over the Beijing Olympics. There's even a company in the UK that offers a wedding package that includes cloud seating, which can be used to burst rain clouds and make them disappear. The company claims they can guarantee a rain-free wedding day. And that will only set you back about $150,000. free wedding day. And that will only set you back about $150,000.
有50多个国家公开实施某种形式的天气改造项目。中国曾试图通过人工降雨来清理北京奥运会上的天空。英国甚至有一家公司提供包含人工降雨的婚礼套餐，可用于击碎雨云并使其消失。该公司声称他们可以保证提供一个没有雨的婚礼日。而这只需花费你大约15万美元。无雨的婚礼日。而这只需花费你大约15万美元。
As the conversation shifts away from the Cold War to the present day threat of climate change, people are starting to talk about the use of geoengineering to fix the problem. Suggestions have been thrown around like brightening the clouds to reflect radiation back into space, or spraying reflective particles into the stratosphere to cool down the planet. People have proposed giant space umbrellas, or even trying to change the orbit of the Earth so that it's slightly farther from the sun. Changing the weather is one thing, but changing the climate on a permanent scale is next-level meddling.
随着讨论从冷战转向当今的气候变化威胁，人们开始谈论使用地球工程来解决这个问题。人们提出了各种建议，比如增亮云层将辐射反射回太空，或者向平流层喷洒反射性颗粒来冷却地球。人们提出了巨大的太空伞设想，甚至试图改变地球轨道使其离太阳稍远一点。改变天气是一回事，但在永久尺度上改变气候则是更高层次的干涉。
Many people are highly doubtful that geoengineering can be used effectively to stop the warming of our planet. Anything we try would be extremely experimental with unknown consequences. That's the main issue. Do we have a right to mess around? Do we have a right to tinker with things and allow things just to happen? Whether it's the free market or some geoengineer who wants to try some new trick. Do we have a right to do that when we know it's gonna have global consequences? Whether systems are so complex, that it's pretty much hubris to think we can intervene in predictable ways.
许多人非常怀疑地球工程是否能被有效用来阻止我们星球的变暖。我们尝试的任何事情都将是极其具有实验性的，并伴随着未知的后果。这才是核心问题。我们有权胡闹吗？我们有权瞎折腾，然后让事情顺其自然吗？无论是自由市场还是某个想要尝试新把戏的地球工程师。当我们知道这会产生全球后果时，我们有权这样做吗？天气系统如此复杂，以至于认为我们能以可预测的方式进行干预，简直是傲慢。
But as long as the stakes are high, whether it's a war, or you know, the fate of the planet, people will probably keep trying. People will probably keep trying. Kurt Coles did and I talk about the unintended reuse of bomb fragments in Southeast Asia. After this. So as we mentioned in the story, the US military has described their efforts at cloud-seeding in and around Vietnam as this alternative to bombing, a way to muddy up the trails with
但只要赌注足够高，无论是战争还是你知道的地球命运，人们大概率会继续尝试。人们大概率会继续尝试。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）和我讨论了东南亚炸弹碎片意想不到的再利用。广告之后见。正如我们在故事中所提到的，美军曾将他们在越南国内及周边地区的人工降雨努力描述为轰炸的替代方案，一种用雨水弄泥泞小道而不是投下致命炸药的方法。
rain instead of dropping deadly explosives. But in reality, US airplanes dumped tons and tons of bombs in Southeast Asia during the Vietnam War era, many exploded on impact. But Colstad is here to talk about the ones that didn't, and the unexpected ways they were reused and incorporated into the built landscape. In the 1960s and 70s, the US covertly dropped hundreds of millions of bombs over Louse. More bombs that were dropped in Europe during World War
但在现实中，美军飞机在越战期间向东南亚倾倒了大量炸弹，其中许多在撞击时爆炸了。但科尔斯塔德在这里要谈谈那些没有爆炸的炸弹，以及它们被重新利用并融入建筑景观的意想不到的方式。在20世纪60年代和70年代，美国在老挝秘密投下了数以亿计的炸弹。投下的炸弹比二战期间在欧洲投下的还要多。在这场后来被称为秘密战争的冲突之后，这个亚洲小国获得了一个令人毛骨悚然的称号：世界历史上人均遭受炸弹轰炸最多的国家，它至今仍保持着这个纪录。
2. And in the wake of this conflict, which came to be called the secret war, this small Asian nation gained the morbid distinction of being the most bomb country per capita in world history, and it still holds that record. It's hard to rub my mind around the concept of hundreds of millions. How is that even possible? Well, a lot of the devices that got dropped were cluster bombs. Basically, these consist of hollow metal shells that open up on their way down and deploy hundreds of smaller explosive bomblets,
我很难在脑海中理解“数亿”这个概念。这怎么可能呢？嗯，投下的许多装置都是集束炸弹。基本上，这些炸弹由中空的金属外壳组成，它们在下落过程中打开，并释放出数百个较小的爆炸性小炸弹，其大小约为网球般大。美国向老挝执行了超过50万次飞行任务来投掷这些和其他类型的炸药。因此，较大的外壳（大炸弹）实际上只是个外壳，而真正散开并在击中地面时爆炸的是大外壳里面的那些小炸弹。
which are about the size of tennis ball. And the US flew over 500,000 missions into Laos to drop these and other types of explosives. So the larger shell, the big bomb, is really just the casing and it's those little bomblets inside the bigger shell that would spread out and explode when they hit the ground. Well, they were designed to at least, but they actually had a really high failure rate. As many as a third of those bomblets didn't detonate on impact, leaving the country littered with close to 100 million unexploded devices. And when the bombing finally stopped in 1973,
嗯，它们至少是被设计成这样的，但它们的实际失效率非常高。多达三分之一的小炸弹在撞击时没有引爆，导致这个国家 littered（布满）了近1亿枚未引爆的装置。当轰炸终于在1973年停止时，老挝人只能自己处理善后工作。
lay oceans were left to deal with the aftermath. So they began cleaning the landscape, but they also started collecting the shells and the scraps they found, and putting them to use in other ways. And do you mean the bigger, outer shell casings or these little bomblets? Well, it's a bit of both, and other types of bombs too, but those big hollow metal shells in particular, yeah, they turned out to be really useful, at least the ones that were relatively intact. Some of the larger ones have been turned into things like canoes. Other mid-sized ones have been lined up to form the walls of buildings or used as spilt
于是他们开始清理地表，但也开始收集他们找到的外壳和废旧金属，并以其他方式加以利用。你是说更大的外壳还是这些小炸弹？嗯，两者都有，还有其他类型的炸弹，但那些巨大的空心金属外壳尤其——是的，它们被证明非常有用，至少是那些相对完好的。其中较大的被改造成了独木舟之类东西。其他中等大小的被排成行充当建筑物的墙壁，或者用作支柱把房屋撑离地面，或者被切割开来做成花盆。
to lift up houses off the ground or cut open to make pots for plants. And even the really small scrap can be melted down for other purposes, like making jewelry or silverware or cowbells or other things. And over time, finding and recycling these shelves and scraps has actually grown into this unlikely national industry. So around the lay ocean countryside, you can see tons of bombshells baked into the built environment. This story has this patina of this uplifting swords to plowshare story, but really,
甚至那些极小的废料也可以熔化用于其他目的，比如制作珠宝、银器、牛铃或其他东西。随着时间的推移，寻找和回收这些外壳和废料实际上已经发展成为这个意想不到的国家产业。因此，在老挝的乡村，你可以看到数以吨计的炸弹壳被铸造进建筑环境中。这个故事带有一种“化剑为犁”的励志故事的光彩，但实际上，这是一份可怕的遗留问题，他们不得不处理我们当初扔在他们身上的这些致命装置。
it's this horrifying legacy that they have to deal with these deadly devices that we dropped on them in the first place. Yeah, it's really very sad. And aside from the people who died initially when those bombs were dropped, tens of thousands of people have actually died due to detonations in the decade since. And even now hundreds of people are injured or killed
是的，这真的很悲伤。除了那些在炸弹最初投下时丧生的人之外，在之后的几十年里，其实已有数万人因爆炸而丧生。即便在今天，每年仍有数百人因爆炸而受伤或死亡，有时是在试图收集炸弹以便重新利用时发生的。所以他们从1973年就开始清理了，他们离清理完所有……你知道的，自1973年以来，他们离清理完所有的炸弹还有多远？
each year from explosions, sometimes while attempting to gather up bombs for reuse. So they've been cleaning up since 1973, are they anywhere close to cleaning up all the you know, since 1973, are they anywhere close to cleaning up all the bombs? Not really. Non-profit organizations that are working on this problem actively still estimate that it will take decades or even a century to clean up the rest of these. And it's this legacy in part that has caused over 100 nations to get on board with this convention of cluster munitions, which is an international agreement
没有多远。致力于解决这一问题的非营利组织仍然积极估计，清理完剩余的这些炸弹需要几十甚至一个世纪的时间。正是这种遗留问题在某种程度上促使了100多个国家加入《集束弹药公约》，这是一项国际协议，承诺不制造、不使用或转移集束炸弹。我猜美国不是签署《集束弹药公约》的国家之一。
not to make or use or transfer cluster bombs. And I take it the United States is not one of the countries that signed on to the convention on cluster munitions. Correct. The US military clearly didn't take away some of the same lessons that other countries did from what happened in the Vietnam War.
没错。美军显然没有从越南战争中发生的事件中吸取和其他国家相同的教训。虽然看到老挝人设法从这些装置中创造出有用的东西很着迷，但它们仍然是战争恐怖的一种非常具体、无处不在的提醒。几年前，摄影师马克·沃森（Mark Watson）在老挝之旅中遇到了这种现象。你可以在我们的网站 99pi.org 上观看他发现的再利用物品的视频。
And while it's fascinating to see how people in the last have managed to make something useful out of these devices, they're still this really tangible sort of pervasive reminder of the horrors of war. A few years back, photographer Mark Watson encountered this phenomenon on a journey through LAS. You can watch a video of the reuse samples that he found on our website at 99pi.org 99% invisible was produced this week by Vivian Lee edited by Delaney Haugh mix in tech production by sheriff
本周的《99% Invisible》由薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）制作，德兰妮·霍（Delaney Haugh）剪辑，谢里夫·优素福（Sherif Youssef）负责混音和技术制作，肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）配乐。库尔特·科尔斯塔德（Kurt Colstad）是数字总监，凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人。团队的其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、艾弗里·特拉夫曼（Avery Trufflement）、特兰·马扎（Terran Mazza），以及我，罗曼·马斯。
Youssef music by Sean Riel Kurt Colstad is the digital director Katie Mingle is our senior producer The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Trufflement, Terran Mazza, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. We are a part of Radio Topia from PRX, a collective of the best most innovative shows in all of
我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心电台街（Radio Row）制作。我们是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的一部分，这是一个汇聚了播客界最优秀、最具创新性节目的联盟。我们由像你这样的听众支持。你可以在 Facebook 上找到我们，参与有关节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（@Roman Mars）以及节目（@99PI），我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。
podcasting. We are supported by our listeners, just like you. You can find 99% of this won't enjoy discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI or we're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But do you know what's better than all of those things? Our website. It's 99pi.org.
但你知道比所有这些都更好的东西是什么吗？我们的网站。那是 99pi.org。
Radio tapio. From PRX. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。